- [Narrator] There are
countless Chinatowns
all over the world, and New York boasts
one of the most famous, full
of cheap produce, fish markets,
and of course, a plethora of Chinese food.
But, if you hop on the 1 train,
take it to the Upper
West Side, you'll find
a Chinese restaurant like no other,
where half the menu is something else.
- Chuleta, chicharrones,
- Ropa vieja,
- Tostones,
- Arroz y frijol.
- [Narrator] This is La Caridad 78,
New York's last Cuban Chinese restaurant.
- Comida china y cree-loya.
- Criolla.
- [Narrator] How did this
unlikely culinary duo
come to be? That's a great question.
Enter Sam Lee.
- Sorry, it's my wife.
- [Narrator] Hundreds
of thousands of Chinese
came to Cuba in the 19th
and early 20th century,
establishing a strong
presence on the island.
But when Castro came to power,
most Chinese immigrants,
like Sam's father, left,
many of them coming to the US.
And thus, Cuban Chinese food was born.
- [Narrator] So are there
any Cuban-born workers left?
(speaking Spanish)
- [Narrator] While
Cuban-Chinese culture is fading,
La Caridad is a snapshot
of a strange moment in time
where two vastly different
cultures merged together.